[Music]
trying to start this whole new life
moving across the country trying to
break into an industry that feels
impossible without having prior
connections and I'm terrified that as
I've heard you say before me will follow
me I'm going to tell you right now if
that's your mindset it's going to eat
you alive it's going to kill
[Music]
you we we are back it's the Dr John
deloney
show Kelly I can see I'm loving this
music man that's what we were just
saying as soon as it starts we just
immediately it's so good I sat down with
Jason I was like listen this has to
groove and and it does I mean when
you're just you're not even I'm not even
paying attention something else and
immediately I'm like just yeah speaking
hey can we just I I know we're getting
to the show it's it's about marriages
and relationships be careful if you're
about to say what I think you're about
to say
I was about to say about this morning I
know but I don't think we
should about who I got to meet this
morning okay no no that's fine not who
you not who you texted me about oh no no
no no yeah let's not say anything about
that just yet all right so here this is
important people have said hey we'd love
to see some more interviews we love them
and um I have a very non-traditional
list of people that I'm interested and
one of them wrote back last night and
was like I'm in and it's a and I now
have his phone
number and Kelly is what some would call
stalker but now this morning I show up
to work and they're like hey deloney we
need you to come meet this guy backstage
and I by the way I knew he was coming
cuz I brought one of my guitars we could
sign it um but one of my childhood
guitar Heroes Brian Welch from Korn was
here today and uh because that's just
where we work right what we do that's
just where we work so the first time he
came which was gosh probably 10 years
ago it was in our old building so I'm
walking across the street to go to dvo
and I see this guy standing outside and
he's pretty distinctive yep he clearly
doesn't work here and I was sitting
there and this guy was out there smoking
a cigarette and I was like is that Head
Welch yeah surely not because why would
he be here and I just was thinking okay
wow we just hired a guy that looks just
like him and when he walked on stage but
gosh his story is just so amazing he's
amazing guy it's incredible yeah yeah um
and just getting to sit backstage and
talk shop like I don't I don't know we
can share or not share but what their
projects are working on all that kind of
stuff it just it was just awesome um and
here here's the thing I I didn't get to
say this much this morning
I remember very clearly Ugly Kid Joe
remember that song like I hate
everything about you yeah such a great
song but they were wearing um jams like
shorts and t-shirts and that's the first
band that did that because everyone was
wearing leather or flannel and I was
like those guys look like me I I
remember that stamp like oh you could do
that and then I remember Phil and Selmo
on the walk video with panta walking out
shaved head and just being like listen
here and I was
like I want I want that and then the
third one of those is when Korn came out
with the song blind and they the the
video was real dark and these dudes have
tuned their guitars all the way down
they'd added another string and they are
adding a Groove that I didn't know was
possible in metal and those are the
three like stamps when I was like I'm
going to do that now clearly I've gone
sideways because now I run like a semi
okay podcast we're talking about mental
health right I spent my years in in but
inside my
soul I'm in a famous metal band or a
punk band and so this this morning was
like my little backstage they were like
what's wrong with you dely I just don't
get Starr and today I was man what a
special day so welcome to the Dr John
deloney show they're probably G to edit
all of that out because I'm still
fanboying and glowing but we're so glad
that you're here we talk about mental
health talk about your emotional health
your your when you get to meet childhood
Heroes and you just stammer on like an
idiot but so glad that you're here if
you want to be on the show here's the
deal show is real people going going
through real challenges in their life
it's tough stuff sometimes it's good
sometimes it's really gnarly but my
promise is uh I've been doing this for
for two decades sitting with people when
they're hurting and we're going to
figure out what the next right step is
if you want to be on the show give me a
buzz at 1844 693
3291 1844 693 3291 or go to John
delone.org
hi thank you for taking my call of
course hey you had to be on the phone
for a long time sit through all the ads
me talking about meeting corn this
morning so thank you for being patient
of course that's fine so I'll just get
right to it um so my question is how do
I move on with my life without regret
after cutting off contact with my mom I
can tell you right now you
don't regrets going to be part of this
this journey what happened
um I know what a what a bum way to start
the start like like you don't so T um
tell me about it what what happened with
your
mom um so I come from a long line of
um generational sexual
trauma um I was sexually abused by my
dad from the age of
five till about 13 but I mean the end
game doesn't matter oh whoa whoa whoa
every step matters it does I'm
sorry but um thank you hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on I don't want to
leave yet I don't want to leave yet as
the dad of a
daughter who I can't breathe if she's
not
okay I need you to know I was wrong and
I'm sorry on behalf of Dad's everywhere
I'm so
sorry well thank you I appreciate that
your dad should have loved you as much
as I love my little girl I'm
sorry and now I have a little girl who
is the same age I was oh when all the
trauma started so it's all kind of
getting yep I bet your body is lit up
like a Christmas tree huh exactly yeah
yes and so um I've actually kind of
started the prosecution process um oh so
you're going for it I'm going for it
yeah I've realized I'm I'm breaking the
generational curse that has been set on
my
family um but yeah so as the everything
has been coming out and talking I've
kind of realized that my mom has not
taken the steps that I would take for my
daughter now and I just have had a lot
of resentment towards her um like I she
found out in eth grade what was going on
and she stayed with him
until I finally again was like listen I
can't do this anymore I was 21 and I was
like I gotta start getting myself better
and I can't while he's in my life and so
um they ended up divorcing and now as an
adult I had asked her like what was
going on like please try and help me
realize why you didn't leave him at the
time and she told me that well
apparently I as an eighth grader told
her that I didn't want to ruin spring
break
plans so I I need you to hear I need you
to hear what I'm going to say very very
clearly okay and hopefully a therapist
has told you this but often I find that
doesn't
happen powerful life altering nervous
system changing trauma
happens when one of your parents
sexually abuses
you and Earth shattering nervous system
trans forming trauma
happens when you get the courage to tell
another
adult and they do
nothing
yeah I put your mom's violence up
against up right beneath your dads your
dad did is evil and wrong and it's
disgusting right there's a there's a
grotesqueness to it because it's so
vulgar right what your mom did was
evil because there's a little girl
coming to Mom and saying will you
protect me and she said
nope I'm sticking with the
monster yeah and then all these years
later when you get the courage to go mom
what happened she blames
you yeah like I'm coming out of my skin
right now and I'm trying to be
cool but I hate this happened to you
so actually I'm going to change what I
said earlier you're not going to regret
this forever I was wrong I was one 100%
wrong that's what I get for talking too
fast I screwed that
up and I think I'm just battling with so
she's been obviously in my daughter's
life
until just last October okay and so now
I'm just kind of struggling with the
how do I juggle and thankfully like my
daughter has not asked about her she has
she just kind of is going on but I can
tell she can feel the the Hostile
tension that I'm going through right now
so I'm just I'm trying not to I'm just
trying to be the best wife and mom that
I can without letting the trauma
completely take over so here's a couple
of really important things
okay I I want to get this out of the way
way
you with with all 100% certainty you
need to have a professional walk with
you through this
okay okay all right and I want you to go
to uh look in your local area for a
trauma-informed therapist
okay okay and that's a special training
that people go through sometimes it's an
entire program that they go through but
it's a way of looking at responses that
makes sense it's really where I mean
that was a lot of my training was there
and that's why I don't I tell people no
you're not broken your body's working
great in what happened to you okay so
that's number one I want to put that off
to the side for a second okay
um how old your
daughter she's five
okay your gut instinct is going to be to
shield and protect
her yes and what she is going to do is
she's going to absorb the tension that
you are feeling walking Rew walking
through hell right you're walking
through it with a sword this this time
but it's still going to be back through
hell right you're going to have to go
through old memories you're going to get
deposed you're going to have your dad's
lawyer if he decides to be even a
further pathetic coward decides to get
one and try to fight you and call you a
liar you're going to have to go through
all those old stories and have people
question your integrity and go through
old high school boyfriend you have to go
through all
that the problem is if you're not it's
you're going to be walking a fine line
I'll I'll talk you through it here but
you're going to have to let your
daughter know that the tension you are
experiencing has zero to do with
her otherwise she's going to do what you
did which is feel that tension in the
home make it your problem to
solve right and so that regret that you
feel is you have been protecting your
mom your whole
life you've been making sure your mom is
okay or doesn't get mad or doesn't find
out your whole life because when your
mom
says um no I'm good I'm going stay with
him that little girl doesn't immediately
go my mom is
evil it goes oh what did I do how do I
fix
this right right and that was never your
job to fix but what we don't want to do
that's how trauma gets transferred
either the act the ACT goes with it
right you abuse somebody which you're
never going to do or right that inner
chaos that turmoil that you you are
fighting and scratching and clawing
every second of every day to give your
daughter something you didn't have but
that angst intention she
absorbs and so it's letting her know
Mommy is really scared today she has to
go do some hard scary things what Mom
well I have to have some scary
conversations with some big grown-ups
that were mean to me when I were
little what happened well that's grownup
stuff but I want you to know that every
day I wake up I'm so grateful that God
let me be your
mommy you see what I'm saying and what
we're doing is we're going to normalize
sometimes your body feels especially
when you're doing scary hard stuff uh
your body reacts a certain way that's
normal that does not impact my love for
you and so it's going to be weird for
you talking through it because nobody's
ever modeled that for you ever right
right and you don't want to go too far
and be like your grandfather like she's
not ready for that because she's five
there will become a SE there will become
time when you when you tell your story
to your
daughter it's just not
now and so tell me about your tell me
about your
mom now is she fighting you does she
want to see her she giving you grief
about babies like how how is all that
working
out no
she's I think she's just kind of I
talked to my brother um a few days ago
and he got to he saw her over um New
Years and I guess she told him that well
she thought it was going to be a little
bit hard at first but it's it's not as
hard as she thought having me cut her
off so that was kind of um I guess the
cherry on the the cake for me
is such a coward I an absolute coward
it's just and I don't mean to talk bad
about your mom but I sure mean to talk
bad about your mom yeah unbelievable
it's just kind of a smack in the face
because it's like okay I understand and
it all kind of came to a head when I so
she's REM married now and one of my um
step sisters was actually dating a
pedophile and we all went to the wedding
and come to find out I I didn't know any
of this so she kind
of I
guess just let me bring my daughter
around a pedophile and everybody knew
except me and come to find out they were
all like oh no we can't tell her we
can't tell her what's going on um but
yeah I just
just there's just been so many different
layers and so with that finding out that
she knew that there was a pedophile
present who was on the sex offenders
list and didn't feel the need to tell me
so I could take the actions into my own
hands whether that be not going to the
wedding or something and so that's when
I kind of was like okay I've I've known
my whole life that I wasn't going to be
protected by anybody and now that I'm a
doll I can protect myself and now it's
my job to protect my daughter and so
good dude that you have turned it this
is what that looks
like I need you to hear me Kayla you
have changed everything this is what
that looks
like as the great teren Terence real he
says it oh it's brutal here's what he
says and I love this quote I'm gonna
butcher it a little bit but um Family
trauma rolls down a hill like a forest
fire
fire until one brave soul stops and
turns and stares it
down and gives peace to Future ancestors
they may never
know what gets left out of that famous
quote is uh and again I I messed it up
but that sentiment is a person who stops
and stares down a forest fire gets
burned badly and that's
you you have to deal with the the pain
of your mom going yeah I don't care was
sleeping with my husband when she was
young good for
her right you got to deal with a mom
that didn't even step between you and a
monster she chose a monster you got to
you got to all of it all of it I could
just go through I'm not going to torture
you with
that and so then you have the brother
going well I don't know man or the
sister being like well come
on this is what staring down a forest
fire looks like so I think the the pain
you are feeling is grief and I don't
know that you've ever been allowed to
sit in grief because you've been too
busy trying to keep yourself
safe right is your husband a good
man yes he is he's the one that
introduced me to your show yeah he's oh
he's amazing then he must be the best
guy ever um when you're
safe you can grieve and here's why
that's going to be hard for you grief
would get you hurt in the past you
didn't have time for
grief you're were too busy trying to
protect yourself from the two freaking
people who are supposed to love you the
most and so this pain you feel isn't
regret you might it might feel bad if
you
will but just because it hurts doesn't
mean it's not the exact right
thing and I'm pretty slow on the just
cut people up I'm telling you right now
I don't see a path forward where I would
ever talk to that woman
again yeah and what that means is you
got to live in a
world where your mom's not going to be
there for you cuz she opt it
out hear me very clearly you did not
sever this relationship she
did she left
you so if someone's in your home
and they smash up your house and they
run out at the front door and get in
their car and
leave just because you closed the door
doesn't mean you kicked him
out right all you're doing here is
closing the
door your mom's burned your house to the
ground enough she got in her car with a
monster and took
off so what it looks like now moving
forward is just a season of hellacious
grief it's G to suck
yeah okay that's why I need you to
promise me you're going to get with a
trauma counselor who will walk with
you I'm going to send you my book own
your past change your future it's about
this very thing not sexual abuse as much
as when everything falls apart I had
this picture of what my life was going
to look like in this scary scary
question what am I going to do now and
dude you're already
there you're sitting with police
officers you're going to make sure this
man um cannot hurt any more people
moving forward and is held accountable
for what he did in the
past you're on your way but we often see
The Bravery story and the strength story
and we don't realize how lonely that is
or how scary that is or how much that
hurts and that's a part of this journey
too I want you to also pick up a book
called Finding meaning by David Kessler
it's the best book on Grief I've ever
read it's a masterpiece
but it will walk you through some steps
and I've talked about all the time
writing yourself letters um uh making
sure you have a daily journaling
practice making sure you've got somebody
that you can call in the middle of the
night as this stuff starts to resurface
it's going to be gnarly and as your
daughter continues to enter into ages
when this stuff happened to you your
body has put a GPS pin in that and it's
going to go young girl young girl look
out look it's just going to start
radiating and people are going to come
over well-meaning people kind people and
your body's going to just be alarm
Central it's okay you're not broken it's
normal there's nothing wrong with you
but we do need to do the work
to learn a new way to respond to some of
those things it's just part of where
you're at but I don't think you're going
to feel regret what you're doing is
right you didn't kick anybody out they
burned your house down and walked out
with the remaining door frame you just
the remaining door frame you just close
the
door proud of you Caleb proud of you
hang on and we'll get you hooked up
we'll be right
back New Year's is my favorite time of
the year and this year I'm committed to
finally establishing an ongoing
journaling routine developing a
consistent and guided daily prayer
practice as well as getting back to
meditating and doing my coherence
breathing exercises on a daily basis one
place where I can do all of this in the
same location is with my favorite app in
the world hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app on planet Earth it has
over 10 10,000 audio guided prayers
meditations and music I use the guided
prayers and scripture readings for my
personal development I listen to the
lowii Beats while I Journal I'm a sucker
for good Loi and occasionally when
things get sideways I return to the app
in the afternoon for peace throughout
the day whether you're a person of
Christian faith who is looking to renew
your way of living or you're curious
about all this Faith talk and you just
want to explore hallow is for you for
listeners of the Dr John delone show you
get three free months of Hall all 10,000
plus prayers meditations music the
lecture series and more all of it by
going to hall.com
delone that's three free months of the
app at hall.com
dealone all right we're back let's go
out
to
Minneapolis I said it right not
Minneapolis Oh that's true you have done
that before Min Indianapolis oh that's
true you've done that before few times
have you scolded me more yeah
Indianapolis so it is mini mini little
appolis miniapolis home
of the
twins great puckets the Vikings yes and
just cold coldness and our friend Nathan
what's up
Nathan what's up
dude dude what's up man it's it's crazy
to talk to you it's crazy talk to you
dude what's
up oh man before before I I say my piece
I just got to say I saw you on the iced
coffee hour and I was like like that's
that's how I found out about you and I
was just like who is this like ex Navy
SEAL looking tattooed guy talking about
empathy and feelings I'm confused but I
love it so I appreciate it I'm far from
an ex-navy seal my buddies here in the
seals remind me you are not us so they
don't even need to remind me they just
can walk by me and my body's like ouch
so no I'm good
but I love those D in iced coffee are
those guys are great man so thank you so
much for being with us what's up yeah so
um it's gonna sound like a quick a quick
ramble but I just have these four bullet
points I wrote down just because I'm a
little nervous so I'm just gonna try and
get these off real quick um so I've
always struggled with making new friends
because I cling on to connections I
already have but I'm starting a to grow
apart from a lot of them I had friends
in high school went to college
immediately met a group but they started
to fade into their own lives and Social
Circles as the years progressed and then
Co happened towards the end of my
college career and I never really uh
branched out after living at home for a
few years uh and being close to paying
off all my student loans I've decided to
go for a a longtime dream of moving out
of state to Austin Texas and pursuing a
career in film making my brain loves to
overthink and analyze every aspect of
making the right decision and it's paral
izing me um I'm scared I'm not
interesting smart funny or charismatic
enough to build the life I'm proud of
once I move across the country I also
feel like I've never quite fully
connected to a community I always see
the differences in me and them before I
see the similarities I'm 25 years old
never been in a serious relationship
trying to start this whole new life
moving across the country trying to
break into an industry that feels
impossible with without having prior
connections and I'm terrified that as
I've heard you say before me will follow
me so what's your question man that's a
lot there dude thanks for sharing
that yeah yeah I guess I'm my my
question
is I how do I
build confidence that in myself that I
have the ability to I guess achieve what
I want to achieve and actually make some
some new friends in a completely new
place because it's terrifying thinking
about moving across the country and not
knowing a single person yeah but it's
just something I feel like I have to do
well you get we kind of have this myth
about confidence confidence isn't
something I can give you confidence is
your body's accumulated
evidence so I would ask you have you
been in situations before that you
thought this is scary and then you went
did it knocked it
out
yeah I I guess I have
um yeah I guess I I I don't know I've
always been socially I've always been
afraid that I'm not I'm not like
interesting or funny enough to to like
people to like me what does that
mean what is interesting or funny
because because dude my in the top
several friends on planet Earth I
have one is a
banker
you know what I mean okay like yeah he's
my closest friends on planet Earth he is
my closest friend because he is an
anchor into Granite he has the same
haircut he's had since he was
four he pays his bills on time always
what his net worth comically surpasses
mine because he just keeps making a
great salary every year and doesn't
spend it because he doesn't need it he's
he's just he wears the same jeans he
wears the same
shirt it's he's just stable and so um I
wouldn't put him on my list of most
interesting or funniest he is hilarious
but in a like a very different way not
in a way that's going to end up on like
sat Night
Live yeah and so um and I could go down
the list of my of my closest friends
what you're talking about is a
performance and that's not how
friendship
Works M and if turn human connection
into a show you will always go home
lonely oh
man uh yeah I feel like I I do that a
lot here's the root question here why do
you not like Nathan so
much like you you like I don't want to
oversell it you hate Nathan you're doing
everything you can to not be
Nathan why yeah
yeah I think um I I it just I guess it
goes back to how I grew up and I I guess
I kind of realized I had like this this
anxious attachment
style um and like this just
codependency um and I never really okay
hold on you just threw two buzzword at
me and I'm Gonna Keep I'm gonna keep
digging on you is that okay yeah and
this is going to help the listener too
because there's millions and millions of
people they like oh well I just have
this kind of attachment stuff that's
fine U or I just I've I'm this integram
number or I'm codependent or I'm OCD or
I'm
anxious those are those those are all
real very very real okay but I want to
get beneath
that why don't you like
you um I guess I just I I like observe
myself like trying to get people to like
me and then I just become like dis usted
with myself okay but the way you just
describe that you are watching a movie
of your own life you're not acting in
it why aren't you the star of your own
movie yeah that's a it's a good question
I I
think um it it I don't know it might
have to do something with like how I
grew up and like you know I I grew up
kind of I still live with my parents and
there it's it's kind of hard to get some
perspective on this because we get along
great now um but I grew up with a very
explosive dad in terms of his anger okay
um and that explains anxious attachment
right yeah I guess yeah and then hold on
don't guess if you if the one man who
was who was put here on planet Earth to
walk you through life to model for you
what love looks like what masculinity
looks like what provision and showing up
and strength looks like and
vulnerability and care
and you're actually Tethered to a wild
dog yeah you spend your whole childhood
singing in dancing and Performing so
that you don't get bit
Fair yeah that's a good way of putting
it and you've taken that same skill set
and try to get some girl to love you
like that and try to get a group of guys
in a dorm to like you like that and what
they're looking at is a cool guy who's
pretty smart and artistic and has Big
Dreams for himself and then why are you
singing and dancing dude like just get a
drink and you see what I'm
saying yeah yeah I feel like I've been
singing and dancing my whole life that's
it you have and uh I'm telling you right
now if you hop into go what you said I
want you to be pay very close attention
to your words and it it's
important you want to go you don't know
if you can cut it and go be a part of an
industry I'm going to tell you right now
if that's your mindset it's going to eat
you alive it's going to kill
you okay cuz the filmmakers don't join
film making to become part of an
industry the woman Sarah who edits my
show is one of the most extraordinary
ciles I've ever met and she gets up
before work and edits she gets after she
gets off of editing my show all day she
goes home and makes her own movies why
not to be part of the industry she works
on my show to pay bills she is obsessed
with storytelling and film making and
how it all works and how she can bring
somebody from A to B through a
story yes that's different than I want
to go make it in an industry because
right now in this season she's having to
work on my crappy show to pay
bills yeah I will be begging her for
filmwork one day when she goes and
becomes a famous director I promise you
because that's that's world does that
make
sense yeah it does I do love
storytelling I I just yeah I look at it
like oh I'm on the outside looking in
and I kind of feel like that's like how
I always feel about certain communities
like I'm on the outside looking in um
okay but here's what's here's what's
really important you have to get a gang
of people where you can just be
Nathan
yeah and as a guy who loves 80s hair
metal and punk rock and I'm a Christian
and I'm real into fitness and I'm
covered in tattoos and uh I like hunting
and I drive a Prius for God's sakes well
now I moved up to a hybrid Highlander
that which is really great for putting
groceries in like I don't fit anywhere
and oh and I happen to have two phds
because I'm a nerd too like um and
you're just as much likely to catch me
at a academic lecture here in Nashville
Tennessee over at Belmont or Vanderbilt
as you are to catch me in the mosh pit
at the Turn Style Show
listen my friend friends love me cuz
that dude's just weird man that's just
who that dude is does that make
sense yeah it does I I've always felt
like oh you know I I I don't know if I
can be a part of this Christian
Community because I don't know my faith
is as strong as them I don't know if I
can be a part of These Guys these like
guys like to party way more than I do I
always see like the differences in in
every Community I step into here here's
your's your isol here's your exercise I
want you to do an
experiment and I want you it's not
really experiment I want you to do some
work and you might have to get a
counselor I hired somebody this year to
help me with a project like
this okay what are your
values okay your beliefs are going to
change I hope your belief Chang your
whole life that's why you make movies
that's why you go to the movies that's
why you read books that's why you listen
to podcasts so a thing you thought over
here is challenged over here that's
awesome but my values are in concrete
they're in
stone right right and so what does that
mean I I don't do drugs man I never
have so I hang out with people all the
time that have very different lives than
me and have very different choices for
what they choose to put in their body it
doesn't it's not even a
thing
right because I have a set of values
here and I'm also going to tell you this
if I had had this level of of success
when I was
28 I wouldn't have made it I'd have
blown the whole thing up okay wow I
wasn't ready for it so here's what I
want you to hear me say I'm going to
give you a couple of really quick things
and I want you to internalize this and
then I want you to go do the next crazy
thing all right okay here's number
one I want you to get get
unfathomably good at the thing you want
to
do right and people overdramatize it
become the guy who always takes pictures
at family
gatherings become the guy who takes
pictures at his local church of families
you know why because you're getting good
at dealing with people and getting them
to act be where you want them to be you
help tell a story through their
photographs and you deal with difficult
people and whining kids and dramatic
adults and you learn how lindes work
that's film making my
friend write every single
day every day of your
life wow okay
here's here's the scary thing I learned
I I went as hard as I could to get a
master's degree in a PhD because that's
what I thought I had to have to have
credibility and I'll never forget the
first conversation I had with a woman
who um who had been sexually
assaulted and I was fumbling for the
things to
say and I remember thinking oh that's
what's important not my degree on the
wall cuz that's not helping this
woman and so I really spent the next
here Me decade of My
Life Learning what to say when
everything had fallen apart in
somebody's
life and then dude I happened along
another degree along the way who
cares right but my Pursuit was not
another piece of paper my Pursuit was
not a job title or a place at this
University or in your case in the
industry my place was there will not
come a situation where somebody's
falling apart that I can't show up and
be a um a moment of Grace a moment of
peace and give them some direction on
what they could do
next so I became really really good at
my job not at the external stuff so
learn how lindes work learn how
storytelling Works do it everywhere
right right always yeah and what you
might find is that dude I don't I'm not
I mean I like movies I don't want like I
don't want to make them that's a
pain or you may find dude I am all in on
this okay the second thing is is your
body's going to feel anxious if you
don't have money if you can't eat if
you're not safe and I know the old
saying is like just go For Broke that's
how you get
broke okay so you're going to have to
work jobs you don't like you're going to
have to work jobs that you think are
different or like Sarah you're going
have to find a job that's industry
adjacent where you learn how the whole
thing works and you do your thing that
you love at
night right your 25 is is going to
happen for a long long long time and
when you get to Austin say yes to every
single project you possibly can I'll
carry water I'll do coffee I'll be a
grip I'll be a whatever fill in the
blank go through all those things keep
doing it keep doing it keep doing it
keep doing it keep doing
it the third thing is stop trying to
find out where to get confidence and go
do things that prove to your body that
you
can I can't overcome challenges I don't
feel confident cool I'm going to start a
dat daily exercise practice and I'm
going to become the most trustworthy
person I know because I tell myself the
truth because when I say I'm going to
work out today I go work out I'm gonna
go do it I'm gon get it done now we're
cooking now we're
cooking you're gonna have to make peace
probably with some professional help
over time H maybe not but
probably with the fact that your nervous
system is wired into love as a show as a
performance and so I want you to
practice just being your weird
self be your weird
self you're exactly as you were made to
be in your experiences and you're going
to get weirder the further you if you go
to Austin I got tons of friends in the
512 you're gonna get weird that's the
name of the town Austin is
weird it's not about being the funniest
it's not about being the best dressed
it's not about being the most clever
it's about being
you and the people in my life who I love
love love love are radically different
than me and I wouldn't call them the
funniest I wouldn't call them the
silliest I wouldn't call them the most
prepared or the best looking or
whatever my friend Craig is way cleverer
than
me my friend Todd is smarter than me my
friend John lets me know oh that's going
to be funny on stage or that's not funny
those guys all do the thing that I do
better than me but it's in a weird over
dinner quiet bankery Finance guy air
conditioning guy kind of
way go be
you the world doesn't need you to look
like somebody else that job's already
taken the world needs you and I know
that's something you stitch in a pillow
but I mean it with all my heart it'll be
weird Nathan we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone some people think
relationships are going to be easy if
they're going to be right
that's almost never true great
relationships get that way because both
people put in the work to make them
great and therapy can be a place to work
through the challenges you face in all
of your relationships whether with
friends people at work your romantic
partner or even how you get along with
yourself so if you're thinking about
starting therapy I want you to try
better help because therapy isn't just
for people who've experienced trauma
it's great for building skills so you
can be the best version of yourself so
you can show up in those relationships
and do your part to make the
relationship great better help is
completely online so it's flexible
enough to fit your schedule just fill
out a short questionnaire to get match
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
extra cost find the PATH forward to make
all of your relationships incredible
visit betterhelp.com dealone toay to get
10% off your first month that's
betterhelp help
hp.com all right let's go out to aomax
Virginia and talk to Keith hey brother
Keith how's it going what's up man I'm
doing great how about you I'm freezing
uh we had a nice little rainstorm last
night and um we got a half day of school
but it's it's kind of chilly right now
there you go we got the tail end of it
down here but nothing like you guys got
so glad yall are all right what's up
brother um I am a coach of two College
athletes um they're my sons I don't
coach them but I am also a offensive
line coach here in the area and these
guys have been playing football ever
since they could breathe um they're your
biological sons and they play football
too yes okay all right great okay and
I've coached them since they were little
little little and um now they're being
coached by someone else
um awesome so yeah and so one one son
transferred from a university to a D1
school to a d D2 school and they're both
now playing in the same University which
is really really cool saves on gas um so
that's been awesome uh for the first
couple years they played quite a bit and
this year for some reason um they have
not played as much um my older son who's
a tight end hasn't played at all
practically and my other son had an
injury in the first game and just
couldn't get back on the field um for
for a lot of different reasons that I
knew about and some things I didn't the
question is how do I
handle this frustration this turned into
anger um over them not playing to the
point where I was unable to sleep um I
was not angry toward my wife and my
daughter who are still still you know
we're all together and we're still live
in the same house but man I was just for
the last 6 months a pain in the butt and
um especially traveling up and watching
them I know this is kind of a different
question no it's I mean I was a coach I
get it and I'm a dad I get it um
yeah I'll just kind of cut to the chase
I
I I say for some reason I get it and
happens very organically but you have
tied your identity to their
performance and bro it's going to drown
you actually what's here's what it's
going to do it's going to burn your
relationship with them it's going to
sever It ultimately and youall have had
this one bond this connection for so
long um it's going to sever it and it's
going to be a lifetime of trying to
repair it and you and I both know old
grizzled coaches whose kids don't want
to come
home yeah and you and I both know old
Grizzle coaches their knees don't work
they got that weird shoulder they always
got a dip in their mouth and their
grandkids are kind of awkward around
them you I both know those dudes right
yes yes so why is it this isn't about
your
boys because you know football in many
ways is a meritocracy that coach that
college coach he has to win to keep his
job so he's going to put the best
players on the
field yes and so for some reason your
boy's not
playing is making you feel less than why
is that
um I I played at a at a school here
locally and um was in all America
and was supposed to be drafted in the
third
round so there were three teams that are
interested in me um and so when the time
came uh to be recruited or they called
before the draft the majority of our
coaching staff said yes he will be a
great asset to your team well the head
coach said no well he was the most
experienced coach out of all of them he
was an NFL experienced guy and he was
trusted in the community and when he
said
no they didn't draft me or give me a
free agent shot so at that point I felt
that no one stood up for me okay can I
challenge you for a second yes sir you
and I also know of
athletes who go to jail who get DWI who
under assault sexual assault uh uh
investigations who get drafted and
drafted and drafted and drafted and
drafted okay is there a
chance that it didn't work
out and instead of dealing with the
grief of I had this dream and it didn't
work out I had this picture of my life
what it was going to look
like that has been easier to take that
whole dump
truck full of crap and pain and dumping
on one dude oh yeah he may have tanked
you there's no question that's
happened no
question but is there a possibility that
it didn't work
out and a second more important
question is dude I can hear it in your
voice
what is hanging on to that getting you
right
now well I think uh since the way I
looked at it and I know I I called or I
um asked this question a couple months
ago so there's some things that I've
done to kind of work through it and kind
of ENT you're avoiding my question coach
what like is that
possible that the story you've told
yourself you weren't as good as you
thought you
were oh no no no I this is going to
sound really arrogant but I was good
enough to play I find that hard to
believe because those dudes have to win
to make money and if you were the best
guy they would have figured it out
because they figure it out for drug
addicts and for uh former people who
committed assault they figure it
out um I mean that could have been a
possibility I
I mean i' I've just had friends who
played in the NFL at that particular
time that agreed with me and the other
coaches of why it didn't happen
Okay I mean I just the fact of it is is
there were too many people that were
telling me that I should be playing okay
but do you realize the step between and
I'm saying this with a smile on my face
if you were here I'd be I'd be ribbing
you but there's a very Uncle Rico aspect
to
this right
right because there's that waking up and
it should have been it should have been
it should have been it could have been
and your whole life is passing you by
like a
train and then you try to relive it with
your
boys yes I totally 100% agree with that
as far as passing by different
opportunities getting my degree late um
and then now just starting to do the
things that I think God has for me to do
and it's become really really awesome
with the things that he's allowed me to
do right now so a lot of it has kind of
moved forward like I said I put a lot of
things that you had said a couple couple
months ago when I asked this question
and read the book and did a lot of cool
things and started to realizing some
things about myself maybe not the
question that you asked the first time
but that could be definitely a reality
but the other stuff I think I'm starting
to move forward through that stuff
that's awesome that I mean I'm I'm super
proud of you super proud of you so tell
me about your your anger with your boys
are you mad at them are you mad at the
coaches are you mad at the universe who
are you mad
at I'm mad at the coaches the boys I
love dearly and we've sat and talked
about this in depth and I've explained
to them that this is not about them this
is about me and that I need to accept
and love and enjoy them no matter what
they do and if they stand they stand if
they play they play but I have to enjoy
them
and love them regardless and I think
that has done really well in the last
several months but man they just knew
that I was not happy yeah yeah and then
you see that they start trying to get on
the field or cut corners or not tell the
trainer just how bad they're hurt or
whatever not because they have this
innate lunacy to win and you and I have
both been around athletes that are like
that dude's different than me I remember
being around a fighter during my
training days and one guy went pro I was
like yeah that guy was that guy was very
different than me right and you you you
know those guys but they start oh go
ahead they start trying to get on the
field so that you'll chill
out yeah
right yeah they tried there's a
particular situation where T should have
run on the field and he didn't and I was
like what are you doing
go so um but I get really anxious and
I'm looking forward to seeing how I
handle this and move through it with
different techniques that I've tried so
far they have one more year to
play um so I'm excited to see how this
kind of looks hey I'm gonna challenge
you you ready for my challenge yes sir
all right here's challenge number
one I want you to go to the games and I
want you to not wear the
Jersey here's why because I'm afraid
that you are cheering in that you want
your boys to do well and everyone in the
audience is going to look at in the in
the stands are going to look at you
that's your that's my boy
boy yeah right 100% right and it's not
it's not about you it's about their life
and one of those boys at some Point's
going to come to you and say Dad I never
really wanted to play he won't fully
mean that but it will come out if it
hasn't already yeah and I also want you
to take an honest inventory because as
as you've told me your story as you've
told me their story it all hinges on
this one guy who just screwed
us and I've just been around long enough
that does happen dude it does happen
but there's a lot of miserable people
whether it's a politician whether it's
an exwife whether it's a coach or a
teacher or a professor or whatever if it
wasn't for this one person or this one
situation and I always want to say dude
what are you gonna do
next yeah and the more you hang on to
that past
Injustice in the present the more you
choose I'm going to make right now
suck
and what a weird thing to right and you
tell you've told your players for years
you got to shake off that last play
Let's get back in there
yeah and what I want to tell you is yeah
I was I was good enough to play I was
and I didn't it didn't work out for me
cool right yeah yeah no that's that's
right my kids when I coach them what
other I know hey trust me dude I see a
counselor myself cuz it's hard it's
easier to tell other people and same
with your boys same with your
boys I want you to ask yourself this
hard question too how much of the
coaching and the football and
the relationship proxy if you will I can
be around my boys I'm gonna be their
coach I'm gonna be their this I'm G be
their this
um I often find dads myself included is
that's an easy I know how to do that
thing so I'm going to do that thing
really really
well CU I don't know how to do the other
thing which is to sit and read a
book which is to be I don't know how to
hug you when you got hurt but I know my
coach said you shake it all and so I
just start repeating
stuff and my guess is I don't want to
say that the time has been wasted it's
been amazing your boys have gotten a
dream they've gotten to walk alongside
their dad and cheer and be heartbroken
you've probably had some conversations
with them when the Coach Line crossed
over the dad line and you'd like to have
that stuff back hopefully you've
apologized as a as a true man to them um
but there's going to come a time when
they just want their dad do you love me
for me
man do you love me for me and maybe
that's the exercise to write each one of
them a letter and just say I've been
your coach for 21
years I need you to know I see the man
you've
become I see the way you treat your mom
I see the way you treat your sister ERS
I see the way you tip well at some
crummy restaurant in the middle of the
night all the football stuff goes away
dude but I see the boys becoming men in
front of my very eyes I want you to know
that I I I almost can't breathe I'm so
proud of
you yeah that's good I have started to
read a book though you're saying that
but I've been starting to read books and
relax and take myself away from stuff
well that I've started to do that good
good good but hey I want you to be a
real gangster I want you to write that
letter and then I want you to get each
boy and read it to him yeah look him in
the eye and read it to him wait wait
wait wait you want me to write it and
then read it to them not send it to them
oh yeah in person oh that's yeah that's
cool I just didn't know if you wanted me
to send them the letter nope I want you
to read it to them okay cool all right
yeah cool I can't wait till you sit down
to do it here's the deal here's the deal
I also want you to write I want you to
write young Keith a letter the Keith the
night before he finds out that his head
coach didn't recommend him for whatever
reason and I want you to write him a
letter and talk about the disappointment
and you had these dreams and you were
going to be on the field and all
that okay and then I want you to tell
them you think that you this is going to
be the way that life has to work out for
you and it's not going to work out that
way but here's how freaking amazing it's
turned out and then I want you to start
writing about your wife
and WR about that extraordinary daughter
and right about those boys who have come
in and out of your life as a coach and
you have been the father for them they
did not have cuz their old man
left and yep you could have played as a
lineman two or three years and you'd
have no ankle mobility and no knee
mobility and one workable
shoulder that's all true and you would
have made some money not anything like
your the other guys behind you that are
getting their name in the paper but you
would have made some
money and instead you've been a part of
transforming family trees for two two
decades I want you to write a letter to
your young son that because I need Keith
in the present to believe that because
everything you're doing right now is
still waiting for this NFL thing to
happen it didn't happen with you so it's
going to happen with your boys didn't
happen with your boys it's going to
happen with my
grandkids put that whole damn story to
bed
dude because that wasn't going to be
what made Keith
Keith the story that was in store for
Keith that Keith was writing with his
life all the way was I'm going to sit
with young men and I'm going to teach
them to get more out of themselves than
they ever dream possible I'm going to
teach them how to show up and do really
hard things that they don't want to I'm
going to teach them how to dig down deep
work as a team all those things that you
get from sports that I love so
much and then you are going to
consciously transform your relationship
with your boys to one where they have to
sing and dance for
you to one where dude I just get to bask
in their glow so I want you to go to
games and not wear the shirt I want you
not I don't want them hearing you
screaming I want them look up and you
just pump a fist and you go that's my
boy right there I love
you and I want you to send him a text
after the game I saw you didn't get in
the game one time and I saw you cheering
your butt off your teammates and that is
amazing you played your part today not
your coach sucks I'm coming after your
coach I to do that
crap cuz some kids are going to start
some kids aren't even going to make the
team and some kids aren't going to
college and some kids aren't going to
make six figures and they're still our
kids we still love them we still
celebrate them cheer for
them hey Keith I'm freaking proud of you
dude I'm proud of
you you didn't fail in my
eyes I'm kind of glad you didn't make
the NFL Uncle Rico I'm kind of glad
CU I'm glad that you were placed in the
lives of all those young
men you planted seeds to trees of which
you will never eat their fruit that's
amazing now go transform it with your
own boys call anytime brother proud of
you we'll be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at johal.com
all right we are back it's time for am I
the problem what's up Kelly all right so
this is from Josh in Bristol Indiana all
right my brother-in-law attacked my wife
on Facebook and then bashed our business
that we own hold on can can we
just what I love this is this is very
very recent modern history where we use
such violent words to describe like
Words sentences on an imaginary world
yeah they attacked me and bashed
us with knives and and sledgehammers no
their keyboard with thumbs ups and downs
all right continue all right so bashed
attacked the wife on Facebook and bashed
our business he he was drunk and being
dumb I no longer want to have a
relationship with him or his wife some
of my family members say to forgive him
because he was drunk but I don't see it
as an excuse I have no interest in
talking to him unless it's about giving
up drinking am I
overreacting my gut says yes I think it
is this the first time
yeah my gut says and and maybe I'm
biased by the initial language
like um but yeah I mean I've Got Friends
in my life that I love that did stupid
stuff and they're drunk and I had a hard
conversation like dude you cannot do
that that's not an excuse like we're
don't like d I'm sorry now I think it's
different if this is just the latest in
a pattern that's right and he refuses to
apologize refuses to get help that's a
different story I'm not to put myself in
the situation yeah right yeah and also I
don't need to make a big a big
announcement
you know what I mean I don't need to
make a
big like I am ending dude I'm just not
gonna hang out with you dude you're
drunk all the time right Talk to Me When
You're Sober yeah or if you want to get
help I'm here I'll always be here for
you right yeah um but if somebody just
does a thing and they're an idiot
online I don't
know you know I mean I love I saw this
on Instagram recently it's some famous
Hollywood actor but he said if somebody
has a true like a real problem with me
I'm me I ask them to call me or text me
and if they say hey I don't have your
number then I don't really care what you
had to say right and I love that
sentiment like um like you're not in
that like you're not in that Circle
that's right you don't get to hurt me or
you know you don't get to have input
yeah but um so there's something to be
said for I don't know dude somebody got
drunk and screwed up did something
really bad did something stupid and mean
um we're GNA sit down and have a hard
conversation yeah cuz why you know do
you have a problem with my wife what's
the problem we need to have that
conversation cuz it came from somewhere
that's right you know and um I'm going
to defend my wife you're not going to
talk bad about my wife publicly you you
know um and it might be that my wife
says oh we're never and then I'm going
to do what my wife right so uh oh they
are never welcome all right well they're
never welcome here so I don't think this
is a yes or the problem or no you're not
just any context yeah um I always air on
the side of reconciliation that's just
kind of my natural bent um I could have
I'm glad people didn't walk away from me
when I've done dumb things and I'm
really really glad I didn't walk away
from other people cuz they're
cornerstones in my life now so I only
haven't because I literally get paid
just so you know what's that I haven't
walked away just cuz I literally get
paid oh no you have to it's yeah one day
you're going to have enough money in the
account you can bar be like peace I'm
out ah awesome all right hey appreciate
you guys thank you for being with us
love you all go listen to some good
Tunes take care
[Music]
bye